foreign
[Music]
concerns lgbtq rights something that
we've actually gotten better at
discussing given that this is how CBS
News covered the existence of gay people
in 1967. the homosexuals with CBS News
correspondent Mike Wallace there is a
growing concern about homosexuals in
society about their increasing
visibility this man is 27 college
educated he was unable to hold a job
because of his inability to contain his
homosexual inclinations
okay that is a big yikes from me from
the wildly homophobic language and the
fact that this man's identity was
concealed by placing him behind a plant
to the title The homosexuals which
sounds less like the name of a news
reporter more like how your grandpa
refers to the Fab Five
specifically we're going to talk about
transgender rights now we actually first
talked about this seven years ago and
the good news is that since then more
people do seem comfortable coming out as
trans and gender non-conforming which is
great but as you have undoubtedly
noticed in the past few years some on
the right have truly lost their minds
about trans rights perhaps best
encapsulated by their favorite new joke
my name is J.R Majewski
and my pronouns are Patriot and ass
kicker my pronouns conservative Patriot
I'd like to declare something right now
my pronouns are USA how about it huh I'm
Ted Cruz and my pronoun is kiss my ass
I do not like that Manta Cruz I do not
like his shitty views I do not like him
saying ass I do not like him serving
sass I do not like him in a seat I do
not like him holding meat I do not like
him when he's smooching I do not like
him with mnuchin I hate his stupid
pronoun [ __ ] that man Ted Cruz is full
of [ __ ] but look it is clearly more than
just bad jokes this year alone over a
hundred anti-trans bills have been
introduced in state houses and 12 states
have signed or enacted them with all of
this happening against a backdrop of
violence and threats including attacks
and harassment aimed at hospitals
providing gender affirming care to Youth
and frustratingly there are many on the
left who seem at best reluctant to
engage on this issue and at worst
outright hostile to it either
complaining about pronoun police or
arguing that this issue will cost
Democrats elections if you go to the
middle of the country people would say
if your conversation during a
presidential election is about some guy
wearing a address and whether he she or
it can go to and and go to the locker
room with their daughter that's not a
winning formula for most people wow it
Michael Bloomberg can [ __ ] all the way
off with that [ __ ] but also while this
fun-sized billionaire is clearly good at
a lot of things like making money and
end of list maybe don't take advice on a
winning formula for elections from a man
who spent over a billion dollars of his
own money to lose a presidential bid in
just 14 weeks
but set aside the notion that it is
worth sacrificing protections for a
vulnerable group to chase a winning
formula let's also remember that it's
not actually the left talking about
trans rights non-stop it's Republic
applicants who see an advantage in
demagoguing this issue and to ignore
them doing that is to allow them to have
real calamitous impact on people's lives
a few years ago voice profiled a girl
named Kai shapley and just watch how
happy she is talking about her hopes for
her future until she remembers something
that changes her mood
yes I might grow up to be the president
the change about the world if you're a
president
um
a chance people be free and go to the
bathroom they want to go to
are you able to use the girls bathroom
at school
now they just put security guards up
oh I hate that that is brutal it is so
dark it's genuinely hard to watch which
would also coincidentally be a pretty
accurate tagline for House of the Dragon
but the point is given what is at stake
here tonight let's talk about the latest
round of attacks on trans rights where
it's coming from and what it's doing and
before we begin we're going to be taking
the arguments behind a lot of these
anti-trans bills seriously because of
what they're doing but not sincerely
because so often they seem to be based
more on political calculation than what
is actually happening a pretty good
example of this is that in recent years
18 states have passed laws aimed at
protecting Youth Sports and South Dakota
Governor Christie gnome even made her
State's Bill a centerpiece of a campaign
ad in South Dakota only girls play girls
Sports why because of Governor Christie
gnome's leadership gnome has been
protecting girls sports for years and
never back down now Governor gnome has a
bill that will give South Dakota the
strongest law in the nation protecting
female sports doing the work delivering
results Governor Christie gnome okay if
you time traveled here from the past and
the first thing you saw was this ad you
would think two things one wow the
campaign centers around Youth Sports I
guess literally every other problem in
America has been solved and two she is
not pulling off that cowboy hat and you
would be right but only about the Hat
part people like gnome love stoking fear
over the Specter of trans athletes girls
specifically having an unfair advantage
and taking away scholarship
opportunities but there are vanishingly
few examples Nationwide of trans
athletes attempting to compete at all
and in no State specifically the head of
their High School sports Association
could name exactly one transgender
female athlete who competed and who
graduated several years ago so there are
more athletes in this shot from gnomes
ad than there are trans girls known to
have competed in South Dakota schools
but even if there were more
discriminated against them would still
obviously be wrong and it would still be
weird that state legislators were
getting involved in decisions that are
usually made by organizations governing
the sports in question and it is worth
knowing even at the elite level
conversations around this aren't being
handled with flat out bands the ioc has
announced that it will set rules on a
sport by sport basis but working on the
general principle that no athlete should
be excluded from competition on the
Assumption of an advantage due to their
gender and it is pretty remarkable that
a trans athlete could theoretically
compete in the Olympics but not in South
Dakota Under 12 soccer a sport that
genuinely only exists to obliterate
parents weekends
and State's blunt force approach has led
to absurd situations like that of Mack
begs Who as a Texas high schooler wanted
to wrestle boys but was forced by state
rules to wrestle girls when he won a
state championship lawmakers tried to
pass a law that would have made it
impossible for athletes like him to
compete period which is obviously absurd
because as one of the wrestlers that
Mack actually defeated pointed out none
of these people seem to think through
the reality of Mac's situation do you
really honestly think someone would
change their entire gender just so they
would win state
no that's not how it works right this
obviously wasn't an effort to cheat kids
aren't plotting big deceitful School
sports related cheating schemes just to
get what they want you're thinking of
Laurie Lachlan that's who you're
thinking of here you're confused
so much of the conversation around
anti-trans laws involves massively
overheated rhetoric that does not match
the reality of kids actual situations
and interestingly a lot of it's been
fueled by some of the same players
behind the critical race Theory Panic
who as we discussed in February we're
using it as a wedge issue to promote
school choice in fact one key architect
of the CRT Panic Christopher Ruffo
recently pivoted to attacking trans
rights and he has openly discussed the
strategy behind doing that what I'm
looking at and it's just kind of an
ongoing series I just started it is to
take that same system of reporting that
same style of reporting as I did with
critical race Theory but now taking a
look at gender ideology what's happening
right now is parents are feeling that
they're feeling though oh this is kind
of weird I'm kind of uncomfortable with
this but I'm scared to speak out and so
what we have to do is we have to give
them the kind of media narrative kind of
a a justification or validation or
substantiation of their concerns to say
hey this is the kind anything they're
teaching in schools and then we have to
give them the language where they can
speak about it with confidence they can
speak about it directly and they could
speak about it with the requisite level
of aggressiveness that it's going to
take to say hey wait a minute we have to
stop this yeah he's basically giving
people a script to repeat and say what
you want about Chris rufo like for
instance that he's a fear-mongering
troll who looks like what would happen
if someone made the recipe for Ryan
Gosling but forgot to add the hotness he
is very deliberate in how he tries to
influence public opinion rufo suggested
branding the discussion of trans issues
under the umbrella of radical gender
Theory and he tweeted out that
conservatives should start using the
phrase trans stripper in lieu of drag
queen it has a more lurid set of
connotations and shifts the debate to
sexualization and sure anything can have
a more lurid and sexual set of
connotations if you just rename it I'll
show you rain Sky Gees they're much
worse immersion blender soup vibrator
spaghetti sauce noodle see this works on
anything
but in the conservative Playbook that
tactic is a really big one linking
discussion of gender identity to sexual
predation and teachers grooming students
our related tactic is arguing that the
rise in kids identifying as trans is due
to social contagion that it's just a
mass delusion a trendy fad that is
rapidly spreading among young people
just listen to Abigail schreier a vocal
proponent of that theory laying all of
this out if you want to see brainwashed
check out these young teenagers who
suddenly decide they're transgender they
immediately cut off their families they
very often drop out of school they are
very often start tattooing themselves
and using drugs and they are creating a
a world for themselves that is so
healthy so built around sexuality and
the they lose all their Hobbies their
only hobby is being transgender
okay so there is a lot there but let me
just address the claim that trans kids
lose all their Hobbies because I will
point out that when they try to have
some like I don't know School sports for
example a bunch of [ __ ] adults try to
keep them from doing it sure sometimes
dresses her argument up by using the
term rapid onset gender dysphoria which
is total horseshit it comes from a study
published by a researcher in 2018
hypothesizing that some kids identify as
trans due to peer pressure but it's
worth you knowing that study was based
on a survey of parents not actual trans
kids and targeted parents from
organizations dedicated to opposing
trans ideology which is instantly
disqualifying it's like citing a study
claiming that all postal workers are
terrifying hell demons sent to attack
your family but then learning that the
researchers only surveyed a collection
of anxious dogs
that's some heavy sampling bias that
clearly skewed your results
and to be very clear there is ample
evidence of gender variance throughout
human history and as far back as
historians have found evidence of trans
people they found trans children as for
the rapid rise in kids identifying as
trans as the writer Julia Serrano has
pointed out when you look at a chart of
left-handedness among Americans over the
20th century you see a massive Spike
when we stopped forcing kids to write
with their right hand and then a plateau
that doesn't mean everyone became
left-handed although there was a rapid
onset South poor dysphoria it means
people were free to be who they [ __ ]
were and to the extent that some young
people are just exploring their gender
identity how exactly is that a bad thing
who the [ __ ] are they hurting watching
the conversation around this it is hard
not to feel like to the extent that
there is any social contagion here it is
among adults who've whipped themselves
into such a frenzy that they can find
themselves repeating some humiliating
nonsense perhaps the stupidest of which
is a new talking point about what
accommodating children's gender identity
has led to I even heard from one person
here recently said that a that a that a
student identified as a cat
and wanted a litter box they think
they're a cat
a cat
they put tails on and they demand that
they have a litter box in the school
we've literally got kids who think
they're cats and dogs using litter boxes
in classrooms I'm still hearing from
students and parents they believe there
is a litter box in that school
And when everybody will turn the other
cheek to allegations of rumors just a
rumor until it becomes true the fact you
seem to genuinely think that that's
happening is just heartbreakingly stupid
because when you think about it for
literally two seconds the whole thing
falls apart for one if kids were using
litter boxes in class a state
representative from Minnesota would not
be the one breaking that news to you you
would have [ __ ] heard about it if a
kid shot in a litter box in first period
it would be the only thing anyone in
that state was talking about by lunch
Minnesota would change its state motto
to Minnesota you know the state where
that kid [ __ ] in the litter box
and notably young people are showing up
in public forums where adults are firm
angry about letting trans kids into
Youth Sports and bathrooms and trying to
talk some sense into them I will not let
a board full of people who barely
represent me tell me who I am and what I
can do grow up and fix your behavior I'm
not worried about a trans person
harassing me I'm worried about if I'm
gonna fail Spanish in my next class I
have used these bathrooms repeatedly
alongside trans people and have never
once felt threatened
you know who I have felt threatened by
the actions of this school board you've
embarrassed yourselves Gardner and the
state of Kansas for your lack of
knowledge and sex and gender studies
you've also highlighted the severely
inadequate sex education week of our
students today yeah the I don't see
those rooms just got humiliated by
teenagers as we all know the most brutal
form of humiliation that there is and
credit to those teenagers for showing up
and skipping whatever young people are
doing these days like hanging out at the
Vape talk store or whatever I don't know
I'll be dead soon
so much
of the fear of and arguments against
transgender people seems to flow from
misinformation and misunderstanding and
maybe the biggest and most dangerous
area of ignorance surrounds the concept
of gender affirming care in recent years
four states have enacted bans or
restrictions on youth access to it and
over a dozen more have considered
similar legislation this year alone and
they have been fueled by a lack of basic
knowledge about what gender affirming
care actually consists of summed up by
comments like this if a child walked
into a doctor's office and said doc I
want you to cut my fingers off the doc
would say you've got some problems kid
we need to refer you to a psychiatrist
if the same child walks into that
doctor's office and says doc I want you
to cut my uterus out the doctor would
say that doctor would say oh well you're
a wonderful Brave person you're so right
we do need to cut your uterus out as
soon as possible let's get this young
lady over to the operating room what are
you talking about absolutely every bit
of that is unrealistic from the fact
that no one in this country has ever
been able to have one conversation with
a doctor without first discussing
Insurance to the notion of a young child
using the term doc why is the fictional
child in this [ __ ] scenario using
the same vocabulary as a chaotic rabbit
from the 1940s none of this makes any
sense but to hear some tell it as soon
as a child declares themselves trans
there is an immediate irreversible
surgical decision undertaken and there
just isn't so let's break down exactly
what gender affirming care consists of
because in younger children it can mean
nothing more than a social transition
like calling them by a new name or
giving them a new haircut or clothing or
or providing them with psychological or
behavioral supports because to be very
clear prepubescent children are not
eligible for medical interventions now
at the onset of puberty an adolescent
and their family might consider puberty
blockers hormones that delay and
importantly if that treatment is
suspended then puberty will resume
meaning that this is reversible think of
it like a pause button the thing you
can't do easily on the HBO Max app
the next potential medical intervention
is usually hormone therapy which boosts
levels of testosterone or estrogen
opponents of gender affirming care make
a lot of alarmist claims about hormone
therapy from saying that it's
experimental which it is not to arguing
that it sterilizes people and look for
some in specific situations there can be
risks to fertility but for others the
effect is anticipated to be reversible
if the medication is discontinued but
there is definitely an informed decision
to be made there and you will notice
that none of what I've mentioned so far
is surgery but when it does come to that
some teens may be eligible for instance
for Top surgery or chest masculinization
but you should know not only is that
pretty rare it like all of this would
only happen after a team of medical
professionals discussed all of its risks
and benefits with their patients and
their patient's parent or Guardian all
of whom would have to sign off it is a
long involved process even before you
get to the fact that it is also
incredibly expensive which is why
working-class families family of color
and people with less resources are way
less able to access it basically no kid
is casually dropping into an operating
room because they just decided to get
their uterus removed with the impulsive
recklessness normally associated with
getting bangs because that is an
absolutely ridiculous thing to say and
the Very notion that the state would
suddenly interfere in any of this is
understandably infuriating for both
trans kids and their parents just watch
this Mom in Arkansas where legislators
were Banning among other things hormone
therapy for young people describe what
it did for her son who suffered from
severe depression before transitioning
I'd say like a month to two months in I
started seeing that kid come back come
out of a shell talk to us more laugh
what did that feel like it was like
that's it this has this has been the
answer all along why would anybody want
to take that away from them there's no
reason why you should be butting in to
my care for my child what do you want to
say to these legislators
[ __ ] you
Royce
[Applause]
back this is not one of those instances
where it is okay to butt into someone's
care for their child this isn't pigpen
and by the way do you need help pink pen
blink your filthy eyes if you need help
pig pen
so the benefits of providing care are
immense and the risks of withholding it
are dire a survey of around 28 000 trans
people found that of those who wanted
hormone therapy and didn't receive it 58
reported Suicidal Thoughts in a given
year which is why the three major
professional associations of Child and
Adolescent doctors psychologists and
psychiatrists have endorsed gender
affirming care and condemned efforts to
deny it and you may have seen or heard
from a small subset of people who
de-transitioned but it is worth knowing
such cases are rare and highly
individualized studies show an average
of just two percent of people who
transition Express regret and that the
vast majority of those who have opted to
detransition did so not because of
changes in their gender identity but due
to external factors such as stigma and
lack of social support and look I could
keep reading you stats and studies I do
after all love doing that
or I could just let you watch this boy
talk about what it felt like to have
someone actually see him for who he was
Dylan explained how as early as fourth
grade he'd had confusing feelings that
stretched on until his teenage years I
really wanted to cut my hair like really
bad and so when I did that that felt
really good and then I held the door for
somebody and they said thank you sir and
I was like oh yeah that yeah that this
little thing little thing uh sir put
words to how I was feeling and I was
like oh yep that that felt nice yeah
that that's incredible for some a
haircut is just a routine activity where
you go to your Barber ask for the
business in the front business in the
back and leave but for a trans kid it
can be a life-changing experience that
boy is currently suing his State's AG in
a trial that starts tomorrow and he is
not the only trans kid who's found
himself forced to become an activist
remember Kai from earlier she's now 11
years old she went to the Texas state
legislature last year to speak out
against bills that would ban doctors and
parents from providing gender affirming
care to young people and she [ __ ]
crushed it there hello my name is Kai
shapley
um I love ballet Math Science and
geology I spend my free time with my
cats chickens FaceTiming my friends and
dreaming of when I will finally meet
Dolly Parton
I do not like spending my free time
asking adults to make good choices it
just it makes me sad that some
politicians use trans kids like me to
get votes from people who hate me just
because I exist
God made me God loves me for who I am
and God does not make mistakes she's
awesome right I wholeheartedly agreed
with almost almost everything she says
there though in the interest of fairness
God does make mistakes if he didn't how
would you explain goblin sharks I mean
just look at this [ __ ] guy he looks
like an eel wearing a shark costume that
doesn't quite fit a sick eel look at
this mess he looks like he's going
if God doesn't make mistakes how do you
justify the existence of this stupid
creep who looks like a child tried to
draw a xenomorph from memory again I
support Kai with my whole heart but to
say God doesn't make mistakes is just
not true Kai he does and they look like
this
and look look I am glad that Kai is
advocating for herself but if a child
has to be an activist we have already
failed that child because she should
just get to be a kid and enjoy her life
and I'm actually glad that you got to
hear her talk about ballet and FaceTime
and Dolly Parton because there is
something that too often gets left out
of these stories and that is Joy while
opponents of trans rights will say that
these kids are either a menace or
brainwashed their Defenders will often
gravitate towards the same sad
statistics that I've shown you tonight
of depression and suicide and while that
is understandable on one level it's the
most devastating harm that can be
inflicted by these bills it's clearly
not the whole story which is that when
supported trans kids can experience full
vibrant lives because trans people are
not by default unhappier or more prone
to suffering than everyone else that is
something that we are putting on them as
that boy that you just saw who is suing
his State AG will point out he's got
other teenage boy stuff going on too I'm
15 I shouldn't have to do this I
shouldn't have to sue the state of
Arkansas because they are trying to tell
me how I can and can't live I have my
collection of hats and and my trans flag
that I got for Christmas is soft-spoken
teenager is more comfortable in his
bedroom he's a bearded dragon come here
surrounded by his fish and bearded
dragon lizards and so he's got a missing
foot and a crooked tail and you know
he's just he needed an extra bit of love
right Dylan should get to be a kid and
spend his time with his collection of
hats and feeding his bearded dragons
whatever the [ __ ] it is that bearded
dragon seats I wouldn't know I've never
owned a bearded dragon although I would
probably get along great with that one
because I too am I love starved pale
creature with a lopsided ass
all the kids we've seen tonight
shouldn't need to be activists they
should get to dress how they want go to
the right bathroom for them and play the
sports they want to play remember Mac
when he got to college he was placed on
the men's wrestling team and just look
at how happy that made him all I ever
wanted to do was wrestleman
and now that I am
freaking dope
it's freaking dope
yeah it is freaking dope do you see that
joy in his face hold that in your mind
going forward not because the road ahead
isn't rough but because as the trans
actress Michaela J Rodriguez points out
it is important not to lose sight of
what is at the end of it when it comes
to legislatives and and laws being
passed we have to constantly stay
diligent and make sure that they don't
get passed and call up as much as we can
but I think also while doing so we have
to live our lives and show people how
happy we are we can't live in the sorrow
though there is many struggles when it
comes to us and the times that adversity
and in the times of Despair I choose
hope and joy and I let those shower all
over those haters and people who don't
see it fit for us and it usually wins
it has one exactly hope and Joy are
crucial here they are the fuel the
powers the ongoing vote for equality and
while there is a lot of fear and
uncertainty right now it is worth
remembering that progress while not
always linear is always possible because
we are working toward the goal of every
trans kid knowing that they are loved
valued and indispensable as Dolly Parton
loving weird pets owning freaking dope
individuals and never ever going back to
a point where anyone feels that if they
appear on TV they have to hide behind a
[ __ ] plant